yeah kung fu is absolutely crazy about
strawberry jam at only 4 months old he's
the youngest resident in the sanctuary
the young bear was just skin and bones
when he was seized from illegal animal
traders fat on Young's been fattening
him up since he arrived
besides kungfu australian NGO free the
bears has managed to rescue three other
cubs so far this year
needn't gonna normally young bears spend
the first three years of their lives
with their mothers but she's usually
killed and the Cubs are kept under awful
conditions kung Fu's brother died in
captivity he probably starved to death
the animals have a really terrible time
this fully grown Asian black bear also
called moon bear is almost 2 meters high
standing and weighs in at 150 kilograms
in cut kwangji sanctuary they try to
keep the animals under the most natural
conditions possible the bear refuge lies
in the north of Laos right next to a
well-known waterfall the nearby tourist
attraction means a lot of visitors take
advantage of the chance to also see the
Bears hardly any of the visitors can
imagine the ordeal these poor animals
have been through like Kobe who lost his
right front leg after he was trapped by
poachers in a snare he was destined for
an illegal bear farm
Luke Nicholson explains to the visitors
that bear bile is used in Chinese
medicine and it commands a high price
in a bear bar farm bears a house in tiny
cages no bigger than the Bears
themselves and they can live up 20 years
inside those pages where bear bile is
extracted through surgical means from
the bear using a syringe imagine going
through that torment of frequency of
every couple of days and you're living
on a subsistence of very very meager
rations of food these pictures show a
bear bile farm near the Lao capital bien
Chan the Bears face is a portrait of
pain nobody knows how many farms like
this are in Laos it's actually illegal
and loves to treat animals like this but
as all too often in Southeast Asia
enforcement and punishment are totally
inadequate Lou Nicholson says the
greatest threat to animals is human
poverty you can find products from the
illegal wildlife trade in almost every
local market here they're popular with
Chinese tourists the bad teeth in these
have been sold for 50 US dollars each we
have a very cool here right next to them
Lao whiskey with animal parks preserved
in them including bits of bear just
recently we've had the seizure on the
lower Vietnamese border of a number of
bear paws which were destined for China
to become Bear Paw suit which is
considered a delicacy and a luxury in
China and demands very high prices the
battle to protect animals and species
can't be won without environmental
awareness so cotton sea bear sanctuary
regularly invites school classes
a lot of the kids don't even know that
or Systema tannaz is resident in their
forest and also a threatened species
more education is needed especially in
rural environments because hunting wild
animals is a way of life there the kids
have to learn that the Bears are so
endangered they might well disappear
altogether from Laos very soon time for
a snack food is hidden in balls so the
Bears can train their natural foraging
instincts
the conservationists are supported by
foreign donors 38 Asian moon bears now
live in the open here far too many the
reserve was only designed to take ten of
them but allowing these colossal
creatures back into the wild would be
too dangerous
there's a number of reasons why these
bears can't return to the wild
some have physical trauma some had
psychological trauma and some have been
hand raised from little Cubs when
they've been rescued the Bears that have
been hand raised it have imprinted on
humans if we were to release them back
to the wild that go directly to a
village looking for food and that's
where we get human bear conflict and
that's when people in bears die free the
Bears is building a much larger refuge
about an hour's drive from the historic
city of Luang Prabang it'll use 26
hectares of farmland it's an ambitious
and expensive project which will offer a
home to 150 bears the refuge is urgently
needed the government of Laos is finally
making an effort to close down the cruel
and the illegal bear bile farms the
rescue Bears will need a new home
tourism integral component of this
development we will be dependent I guess
on the tourism dollar to be able to
drive this project for the duration that
we're looking at it's a massive
undertaking this gonna cost a lot to
build and of course it's going to cost a
lot to operate today some monks have
come from the nearby village of tat
kuang see
they bless the conservationists work
with a Buddhist ritual the ceremony is
supposed to bring luck to the workers
there and fend off evil spirits
free the Bears certainly needs every bit
of support it can get so that Kung Fu
and his friends can enjoy a brighter
future in Laos